Israelis held their breath held their
heads or even called on a higher power
as it became clear that something had
gone wrong national TV carried live
images from inside the control room and
there the tension was palpable
when the news that the landers crash was
announced there was solemn applause but
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
Project Chiefs tried to stay positive
about the outcome you win some you
listen if at first you don't succeed you
try again the spacecraft was called
Bereshit which translates literally into
in the beginning it hitched a ride into
space aboard SpaceX's Falcon 9 rocket in
February this year the mission was an
attempt to make history it would have
been the first privately funded
spacecraft to land safely on the moon
but nevertheless the project did achieve
some milestones we have achieved an
amazing success in bringing a spacecraft
to the moon always bringing to the
landing it is by far the smallest the
cheapest spacecraft ever to get to the
moon so despite the disappointment there
is reason to celebrate the project paves
the way for future low-cost lunar
exploration for more on this mission we
have Leah outlet with us from DW science
good morning Leah good morning so what
went wrong on this mission it was a
crash landing it was really during the
last seconds the last few seconds just
before the touchstone there were only
150 meters apparently above the surface
and then Mission Control lost
communication for some reason so we
don't really know what happened during
those last meters but well they say that
maybe the main engine had a problem will
maybe see in further investigations but
what is clear is that the better sheet
lander wasn't very robust as it's
privately funded it was it needed to be
cheap so there was no backup for
communication system
for the solar panel to keep costs low so
close hundred fifty meters from the
surface and then it went wrong how big
of a setback is this for the Israeli
space program so the big goal was to be
the first nation on the moon this dream
obviously crashed right and even though
they were so sure it to make it if you
look at that Twitter feed there was one
person that tweeted if they will if they
land on the moon successfully they will
be the first nation on the moon and they
corrected not if but when so that shows
it's not a very scientific approach it's
more of a demonstration of we can and
now they try to be optimistic and to
still say it's a success because they
came this close they did come really
close and they actually got there their
Lander on the moon but just not in one
piece what exactly was the point of this
mission well it was more of a political
mission than a scientific one there
wasn't much or big science on part but
it was packed with emotions and with
symbols there they had the national
anthem they had photos of Israeli
landscapes they had the ticular
Declaration of Independence of Israel so
they really wanted to create this kind
of pride in in Israel and also to
promote signs among the new generation
and that was still successful there were
many kids wearing spacesuits for example
yesterday to watch this this event so
yeah this was successful despite the
crash landing so they do have reason to
be proud - thank you so much Lilia from
DW science